many have turned out to be hoaxes others
more serious as threats on social media
we're talking about the wave of creepy
clown sightings across the United States
going back to late August there have
been dozens of reports of threatening
clowns largely centered around schools
and colleges many have been dismissed by
law enforcement as pranks but more than
a dozen people have been arrested in
connection with the sightings Don Dahler
is here with more on this troubling
trend Don good morning good morning well
whether they are pranks threats or
actual sightings police and other
officials have to take them seriously as
a potential threat to safety and that's
starting to drain resources from law
enforcement agencies who are also
concerned about feeding into hysteria
there are concerns tonight that these
creepy clowns and threats online will
continue to grow a woman claims she was
attacked by a man in a clown suit just
this morning it seems as if a new report
of a threatening clown pops up by the
hour police have their hands full with
these possible sightings clown
reportedly appeared inside these woods
this week fourteen-year-old in
California was arrested when he
threatened a middle and high school on
an Instagram page called Fontana's
killer klowns we've heard that people
are going to show up on campus but we
haven't seen anything police say the
teen wanted to scare people and gain
social media followers police in
Connecticut dealt with a similar social
media threat targeting several schools
in the New Haven area while they
dismissed it as a hoax they're still
taking it seriously at this time we are
considering this to be nothing more than
a prank and harassment fueled by social
media upcoming Halloween working with
the police department and our own
security team we have no evidence that
there is a credible threat to students
or schools in the district discussion
affinity of blue hat blue curly hair
polka-dotted bring those colored outfit
it appears to have been much more than a
scare near san francisco on wednesday a
mother says she fought off a person
dressed as a clown who grabbed her
one-year-old daughter i thought he was
going to kiss her hand
instead he pulled her on literally so I
put her on back and I kicked him right
there at that tree back there the
phenomenon started in late August when
children in South Carolina reported
seeing a clown beckoning them into the
woods but those sightings were never
confirmed the cloud scare was even
brought up at a White House press
briefing this week i'm wondering if
presidents aware of this phenomenon and
the White House wants to say anything to
discourage these types of friends yeah I
don't I I don't know that the
president's been briefed on this
particular situation some are so upset
by the perceived threats they're ready
to take the law into their own hands
hundreds of students at Penn State
University launched a late-night manhunt
after a clown was reportedly seen on
campus it's that type of behavior that's
put some professional clowns on edge
I've been flipped off I've been mooned
I've had trash thrown at my car I've
been experienced excessive profanity
while performing so why are so many
people playing into the panic hoaxes and
attempts to frighten people and people
buying into it have happened throughout
history but we're right for this right
now because of social media which allows
a fear to propagate globally very
quickly and because right now we are a
country very anxious about other pneus
in addition to the suspects accused of
making online threats some of those who
have been arrested are charged with
making false reports making this whole
situation even more frustrating for
police officers all over the country you
think about the resources with you and I
will one call in there if it's not
resources that are needed there being
wasted it's true but I tell you I have
two kids in middle school and they are
scared to death there was a high school
in New Jersey just last week that went
on lockdown because a clown was reported
on the campus yeah oh it's just it's the
wasted resources the police it's so
disappointing all right Don thank you
very much Don Dahler reporting